each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so we supply sure to have Tom Malkin
speaking today um talented professor at
Columbia and she's well known for work
on by Park separations of cryptographic
primitives and multi-party computation
and today she'll be speaking about
public key cryptosystems thanks ok so
I'm hi everyone um first of all I
understood my initial announcement said
I'm a CEO of something so I'm not if you
want to leave the room now it's ok and
I'm going to talk about a line of
research it has several different works
within the same line of research that is
about making public key cryptosystem
stronger I wasn't sure who the audience
would be so it I will try to make it
general without too many technical
details and I have millions of slides to
go into if you have questions at the end
or you want to talk to me afterward ok
so here is the outline of my talk I'll
start with a force light version of the
entire talk and then I'll move on to a
many slide version of the same duck ok
so we're starting with a force light
version so um public key encryption I
know you all know what it is but let me
go over it both for consistency and for
motivation so public key encryption the
idea was given by a DC and hellman in
the 70s and the idea is basically
informally Alice and Bob want to
communicate securely over an unsafe
channel ok and the whole point of modern
cryptography started from defining
really what does it mean to communicate
securely what the securely mean and what
is an unsafe channel mean ok so
basically showing that you can in fact
define it rigorously and you can in fact
achieve these definitions by
construction that probably achieve the
definitions typically relying on some
assumption ok like factoring is hard or
anything else the point is the
assumption needs to be well defined well
understood easy to refute easy to study
etc ok so the first such a definition of
security was given by God racer and
Macaulay in 82 of something they called
semantic security
okay and for them they read this kind of
what securely means and the blue is kind
of what unsafe environment means or you
know how is it unsafe so for them they
define security as secrecy okay namely
you hide your message against the
passive adversary an eavesdropper okay
and this is called semantic security and
already is hard to define and hard to
achieve that they did it in the 80s okay
however as cryptographic applications
become more prevalent in there many
different settings this kind of security
is no longer enough for many
applications okay just the passive
adversary is just not enough so this is
a list of stronger attacks I could list
more but these are the attacks that have
solutions for these are attacks that are
stronger than just a simple passive
adversary okay and we want to protect
against them as well so for example this
is all at this point not informal so
let's assume the adversary is not just
the passive eavesdropper who sees what
you send over the line but for example
what if the adversary can change the
ciphertext while it's in transit ok
that's a man in the middle attack or
malleability or what if the adversary
can actually get to the decryption
protocol has access to your decryption
protocol can you learn something that's
called chosen ciphertext attack there's
an adversary that can adaptively an
adaptive adversary somebody who can
let's say some protocols are running the
adversary will see what's going on and
based on that will decide where else to
break into ok that's a strong adversary
you could also owe their previous or at
least in the 20th century all the
cryptographic algorithms assume some
secret key say on which all the security
real ID and the secret key is assumed to
be totally secret ok but that's not
really realistic the secret key might
leak either by malicious insiders or
stupid people or by side-channel attacks
or all kinds of ways the secret key
could leak or the secret key could be
changed with some tampering attacks so
all these are strong adversaries that
are not captured by the previous notions
of security by semantic security ok and
we want to protect against them as well
so this line of work I'll be discussing
is about protecting against these
stronger attacks and I'll focus
specifically on public key encryption
although in general this approach could
be
defined for many cryptographic tasks so
um so this is our goal number one goal
is to have secure against a stronger
attacks as possible however we would
like to do it from with the following
principles so first of all we want to do
it based on the most general possible
assumption okay so what does it mean
most general possible assumptions i told
you that everything when you proof
security you need to assume something
okay we want to assume as little as
possible okay the best case that we
would like to achieve is if you start
from an encryption scheme that's known
to be semantically secure namely it's
only known to protect you against
passive adversaries can you do anything
in order to make it secure against
stronger adversaries without adding any
extra assumptions any extra anything I
mean you might change the protocol but
you don't the proof of security will not
need any extra assumption this is
clearly the minimal one right when you
start with a weaker one you can we call
it immunize you can immunize it to get
stronger security without any extra
assumption okay so that would be one
goal to have a few or some as small
assumption as possible and the second
goal would be to use the underlying
primitive in a black box fashion so what
does it mean what is this underlying
primitive let's say this is what I do I
start from semantically secure
encryption namely week passive
encryption and want to achieve some
strong encryption okay so i would like
to use the weak encryption the
semantically secure encryption in a
black box way you can think of black box
way as something as a subroutine okay i
don't need to know anything about what's
going on I don't want to assume any
algebraic properties I don't know my
tomo morphism some field properties I
don't want to assume any of this I want
to assume I have a black box I have a
subroutine that is guaranteed to be
semantically secure can I use it to have
guaranteed strong security okay so i
don't know if you were counting but this
was the third slide in the fourth slide
version of the talk so I just wanted to
motivate why did I come up with these
two requirements obviously I think the
first one is clearly well motivated than
we want to protecting and stronger
adversaries why do I want week
assumptions and black box fashion so
this is interesting about theoretically
and practically so and even this bullet
I don't even know which ones are
practical
which one a theoretical they both are a
mix of all but we want to achieve as
minimal assumption as possible in a
black box construction for several
reason one it will really give us
insight into the primitives and so this
is like complexity theory for
cryptography ok which primitives can be
reduced to which is this assumption
sufficient for that so and you know what
what is it that you need to assume so
when you have both so this the second
bullet more possible instantiation
refers both to the black box and to the
minimal assumptions so clearly one
obvious reason we want to minimize
assumptions that's a well-known golden
cryptography is that we want our systems
to be secure okay so if I only did the
system based on one specific assumption
I don't know maybe tomorrow somebody
will break that assumption and it won't
be secure anymore so clearly i want as
weak assumption as possible if i could i
would like to do it without any
assumption but that is not possible for
public key encryption and foremost
cryptographic primitives so i want
security to be possible under any
possible instantiation okay so if
somebody believes in elliptic curves and
somebody else believes in hardness of
some lattice problems I want them both
to be happy that this scheme can be
satisfied okay so so so this is clear
for minimizing assumption the truth is
even for a black book the black vote if
you use the underlying scheme in a black
box manner without relying on any
properties that means you can
instantiate it with many possible
assumptions even if in the future
somebody else will come up with a new
assumption by which to build semantics
least secure public key encryption I
would immediately automatically have
stronger public key encryption without
needing to assume any any algebraic
property so for example a good example
of it is all this there's a new wave of
result in crypto based on hardness of
learning and random codes and they don't
tend to have the nice of drag properties
that the number of theoretical
instructions used to have and still we
could use them okay so we could get new
constructions with more assumptions and
finally black box constructions tend to
be much more efficient we are not sure
if this is
inherent something inherent to black box
constructions or just because we don't
know any better but but the fact of the
matter is the constructions that we have
the darn on black box are much less
efficient they typically involve some
kind of an NP reduction cook 11
reduction they're very heavy they often
on black box reductions often have some
kind of cipher text size that depends on
the computational complexity of the
underlying skin and black box
constructions are much more efficient in
all the black box constructions were no
are much more efficient so these are my
motivations for doing this ok oh this
one backward ok so that's basically it
for the general view of my talk so what
I'm going to do now is talk about these
different bullets define what is the
goal that we want what are these
stronger attacks and say what we can
achieve and maybe touch upon the
technical details depending on your
interest ok ok so hmm the topics for
which will show constructions of strong
public key encryption I'll start with
showing then malleable encryption so
from semantic security to none
malleability then i'll talk about chosen
ciphertext attacks security then i'll
talk about adaptive security and i just
wanted to mention but i'm pretty sure i
won't have time to talk about tampering
security against tampering attacks or
leakage of the key ok and i didn't list
all my co-authors because there are many
its many different talks but i'll
mention them as i get to those results
okay so um ok so let's start with just
defining more clearly what semantic
security is so in order to defend before
i define pop a semantic security for
public key encryption i just want to say
the general structure of how we define
security for cryptographic protocols is
as follows we need to define two things
right we need to define the adversarial
model that so i want to build a system
when is it secure so one I want to say
which attacks am I going to protect
against ok this is one of the things I
want to improve so that's the
adversarial model that
includes I don't know the adversaries
polynomial time or just linear time or
whatever you want what he can see what
access limitations he has so that's one
and two is what the meaning of
securities okay namely what should the
adversary do for me to consider my
system broken okay so these are the two
main components and once we define it we
need obviously to design protocols and
the way the proofs go for such protocol
so first of all we want them to be
efficient and then we the provable
security means that as long as the
adversary is limited as in one then no
break is defined in two is possible and
that gives you tells you exactly what
you can get for sure and exactly what
you cannot get okay this gives no
guarantee of what happens if the
adversary goes outside the model and
it's not restrict it doesn't want okay
but it gives you full security when for
this adversarial power okay and for this
meaning of security so obviously we want
security for we want the two we want to
achieve security for an adversary that's
as strong as possible where the notion
of security is as weak as possible like
we want even the smallest thing to be
considered a break and we still want to
achieve security that clearly WingMakers
came stronger and we want the
computational assumption to be as weak
as possible as i said before okay so
that's some general crypto stuff when
applied to public key encryption so
we'll define public key encryption as
follows will have so this is mostly for
a notation will have 30 public key
encryption will be defined by three
algorithms gee the key generation
algorithm that generates public key and
secret key using some randomness that
gets random as an input generate public
key secret key encryption algorithm will
get the public key and a message of some
randomness and generate a cipher text
and the decryption algorithm would get a
secret key in the cipher text and will
give you back the message okay so this
is public key encryption and for
semantic security we assume that the
adversary eve is just eavesdropping and
sees everything that goes on sees the
public key and sees the ciphertext okay
so now how do we define what in security
for this for public key encryption so
first we want to define the power of the
adversary as I said and then we wanted
what it means to break the system so the
power of the adversary here are some
typical common definitions so perhaps
not the weakest with the weakest one
that people use is adversary that can
have chosen plaintext attack what is
chosen plaintext attack an adversary
that simply sees the public key for
public key encryption seeing the public
key you can generate yourself as many
encryptions as you want so it's called
chosen plaintext because you can choose
whatever plain text you want encrypt it
and you see the encryption okay so this
is what the adversary can see for chosen
plaintext attack chosen ciphertext
attack says the adversary not only can
see encryptions of his choice he can
also see descriptions of his choice ok
get some temporary access yes so in this
talk I won't even talk about the
difference but everything I say is true
for both of them it just that I'll have
both negative and positive results or
negative results is stronger to state
them with CCA one and for positive
result the strongest that to stand in
with you see a two so I didn't want to
mention it but yes CCA one sec eight to
it depends on when did you get access to
the decryption Oracle but this is a
stronger adversary right that can
actually access the decryption Oracle
and asks say here's a ciphertext what is
the decryption here is another
ciphertext what is the decryption that's
a stronger attack and even stronger ones
that these are less traditional our
adversaries that can read some of the
key part of the key maybe all of the key
or adversaries that can change the key
in an arbitrary manner or some specific
manner okay so these are different
adversarial powers and now we also need
to define what is what is a breach of
security so there are many ways to
define a breach of security and one of
the first things people think about is
Oh recovering the key would be a breach
of security right that's obviously a
breach of security if I have a public
key encryption scheme and the adversary
whatever power we give him CCAC PA can
see what's going on and recover the
secret key that's clearly a breach of
security but defining this is not good
enough because there are other things
the adversary could do so say maybe I
have great security the key can never be
recovered still the adversary could
possibly recover the message that was
encrypted that's also clearly a breach
of security
and what if the adversary can't recover
the message that was encrypted but
instead that could figure out if two
encryptions to cipher text belong to the
same message or not well it's for some
applications this is no big deal fine
but for other applications this may be a
big breach of security again as I said
we want to define a breach of security
the weakest way we can achieve so that
we can use this in many applications ok
so this underlying one is the one that
is is the one chosen for semantic
security definition ok so for semantic
security definition a breach of security
is being able to recover any information
whatsoever about the message ok so
semantic security is if you can prevent
an adversary from recovering any
information whatsoever about the message
ok so no matter what he whatever he
knows in advancing the encryption
doesn't give the adversary and I any
extra information so this is equivalent
to indistinguishability an equivalent
definition is to say if the adversary
sees an encryption of 0 and an
encryption of one the adversary cannot
tell which is which even if he knows for
a fact that this encryption is either of
0 or 1 ok and it turns out that it must
be randomized so any questions so far
this is this is all this is semantic
security any questions ok so I'll show
an example because I'll use it
subsequently in several stronger
definitions so al-jamal public key
encryption here is how it works I'll go
quickly over it so for key generation
the public key is P G and H where p is a
prime and G is a generator and H equals
due to the X mod p and the secret key is
X ok then to encrypt a message m you
take a random are you and you take G to
the r and h 2 dr times m that's anybody
can do the encryption and to the Crypt
when you get a pair one is due to dr one
is h to the r times m supposedly you do
just c2 over c1 to the x and if you
check it it works ok if you have the
secret key X adjust the algebra porks so
I
this turns out to be in CPI is the same
as semantically secure this notation
refers to the indistinguishability that
semantic security against chosen
plaintext attack so this turns out to be
secure semantically secure so against
chosen plaintext attack this is totally
secure because when the passive
adversary the passive adversary can only
see the public key PGH and the
encryption g2 drh to the r times m and
it turns out if you assume some
assumption called the defilement
assumption decisional diffie-hellman
assumption you get security ok so I'm
going to use this as an example later ok
so um so this can provably and it's not
too hard to prove provably secure
semantically secure but this is not good
enough and I wanted to demonstrate why
so one particular way to for a stronger
adversary to break it so think of an
auction example ok so one way to do an
auction I'm simplifying here but one way
to do an auction is each bitter sends
their bid encrypted and then the seller
you know chooses the highest bidder or
whatever algorithm he wants to use ok so
if we use elgamal for this for
encryption which we know is semantically
secure so it leaks no information this
encryption leaks absolutely no
information to the adversary knows
nothing so the first bidder sent his bid
that's the el-gamal encryption jutsu drh
to dr times the bid right the bid is the
message the second bidder let's assume
is is corrupted this is the adversary ok
we said before this is semantically
secure so he has no idea what bid one is
no information whatsoever about with one
nonetheless it's very easy for him to
bid twice as much ok he would just take
this is all you know mod p he would just
take the second element and x 2 multi ok
very easy that immediately generates an
encryption of two times bid one ok so
this guy the second bidder managed to
bid two times bid one without knowing
anything about bid one without breaking
any security to finish in all the
security the semantic security still
holds but this shows why it's not good
enough semantic security for this
application it is good enough person
their application okay so with algum are
with other encryption scheme with RSA
with all kinds of encryption schemes you
can do similar things they're called
modeling vulnerability so this gives
rise to another requirement we want to
have at least in such set in some
settings like options we want the
encryption of two messages to be
independent of each other even if you
see some encryptions you want not to be
able to generate any other encryptions
that are similar to it okay and this is
called nan malleability so that's the
first type of stronger scheme will talk
about none malleable encryption so this
was initially the fact defined by the
left work in or and there are several
iterations of this but basically the
definition is given some encryption it's
infeasible to generate any correlated
cipher text of the encryption ok so if
for example if you have an encryption of
em you shouldn't be able to generate an
encryption of to em ok so I
indistinguishability in semantic
security are the same so the way this is
stronger definition is in the previous
definition we had in semantic security
we wanted to say that the adversaries
output will be the same no matter what
you get whether she get an encryption of
zero and encryption of 14 none
malleability we want her even if she
doesn't know what what what encryption
she got we don't want her to be able to
generate any other encryption whose
decryption depends on what she saw ok so
the decryption of what you get looks the
same no matter whether she saw an
encryption of m0 m1 so i can give you
formal definitions do you want them or
should i skip them let's skip them ok so
that's the definition and malleability
is stronger it always implies
indistinguishability and notice that
there are two things there one is what
attack you get so we'll talk about
chosen plaintext attack and in chosen
plaintext attack it's not clear whether
indistinguishability strictly weaker
than and malleability or not ok these
are 2 so 4 4 chosen ciphertext attack it
turns out it's not trivial it's a result
it
turns out that features and ciphertext
attack it's the same being
indistinguishable is sufficient to get
man malleability but for chosen
plaintext attack it's not clear and this
is the question we'll ask can you use
indistinguishable can we use
semantically secure encryption which is
indistinguishable under chosen plaintext
attack to get none reliability which we
want okay so in other words can we
immunize any semantically secure public
key encryption against malleability
attack okay and for this question most
of the results I'll show I'm focusing on
questions where the answer is yes we
have results where the answer is no but
most of the things I'll show will be
focusing on the yes so the answer is yes
we can do it so this is based on all
kinds of work but but the last one is
done work with a single Cho and then a
document solid and hot like we and
here's what we do so starting from
semantically secure encryption so you
have GED we'll use it in a black box way
to generate none malleable encryption
okay so if you give me an algorithm for
kid generation for encryption for
decryption I'll give you an algorithm
for key generation encryption and
decryption for a scheme that achieves a
stronger level of security okay of non
malleability yes so you're saying that
we've given this then you can construct
another emergency yes it as in the
previous one forces you to kiss the best
here because I'm is easy to in the same
scheme yeah that's a very good point so
in all my talk when I say does this
imply that I'm thinking I'm kind of
repeating the question as I'm answering
it in all my talk when I say this
implies that i'm talking in terms of
complexity theoretical if you give me
this scheme can i change it massage do
some other scheme that achieves the
other thing i'm not talking about if you
give me a scheme and you proved a can I
prove be for the same scheme okay now so
for because for semantic security this
is not true for example we saw an
example elgamal is semantically secure
and is not none malleable okay but the
question is if can I change elgamal to
be non malleable or can I change any in
a black box why any scheme you give me
that you proof for me semantically
secure can I show you what to do with it
in order to get none malleable
encryption and this is what the answer
is yes for and you write the
the CCA to that in CCA to their
equivalent even for the same scheme but
that's not the definitional use here
here i'll use is there and
transformation is there any way without
so I'm talking about the complexity I
don't want to add any extra assumptions
and I want to use it in a black box way
I can't hear you it was another people
by a visual of them
yes I'll talk about it or not really
talk but i'll mention it I'll have it so
I'll answer your question quickly they
have they don't have it in a black box
way and it's less efficient in its nine
black box that's the short answer okay
so you know our key generation algorithm
and encryption and decryption our key
generation algorithm of the new scheme
will call the key generation algorithm
of the old scheme then not the
encryption algorithm in decryption
algorithm will each call the
corresponding algorithm in the
underlying scheme and also the key
generation algorithm okay so this is how
it works I mean this is the statement of
the result I didn't show you how it
works so here is this is the this is
exactly the same as the next scheme the
next scheme is word heavy and this is
picture heavy but it's going to be
exactly the same thing so this is just
to have like an official statement of
what we do so assume you had a
semantically secure encryption scheme
then there exists you see I'm not saying
it's the same scheme I'm saying there
exists another scheme that is not
malleable encryption scheme and this
notation means it's black box okay it
calls the other protocols in a black box
way okay and this is obviously the
minimal assumption necessary cuz
nominally building apply semantic
security so you must have some semantic
security so our main technique is
something you know so this result
existed before in a non blackbox way and
there they used a there's some issue of
zero knowledge and all of these non
blackbox techniques there's some issue
of zero knowledge which I'll say in
short if you don't follow it doesn't
matter but in general sometimes when you
have some scheme and you want to achieve
a stronger scheme one way to do it is to
somehow run the first scheme and on top
of it ran some zero knowledge proof to
prove that you're doing things correctly
and that typically is extremely
inefficient okay because these proofs
usually go through some complicated NP
reductions and that's so complicated but
like we use some statement we say it's
an NP statement therefore its reducible
to three color ability therefore we'll
do something okay so
that's that's highly inefficient so our
main technique here was over using
previous work our main technique is to
manage to verify consistency of
encryptions in some zero knology way but
without using the inefficient zero
knowledge instead we use some error
correcting code techniques okay good so
this is a picture so the red one is our
result and this is a picture that
mentions the result we mention for this
is kind of a picture of what was known
before if you don't know any of these
results it's better probably that you
ignore this ah slide but if you know
some results this puts it in context of
what was known before so in CP a
semantic security we showed that it
implies none malleable CPA okay in a
black box way before that it was known
in 06 by a pastula and Vic Quinto Nathan
showed how to do it in a nun black box
way okay and the way this graph is is
done the CCA to CCA to is a stronger
definition than non malleable CPA okay
and in fact we knew already what we knew
how to the best result in terms of
assumption in terms of most general
assumption the best result we knew for
how to achieve CCA to was in fact
already from DD n the left work nor but
they did it first of all with extra
assumption they couldn't do it directly
from semantic security they needed some
extra assumption for zero knowledge and
it's also very inefficient okay so now
we did it in a black box way and with
fewer assumptions but we didn't quite
get to CCA to we only get to none
malleability okay so wait so at this
point I can take a detour and explain
the construction for you that will
probably not leave room for apps why I
don't know what you prefer would you
prefer me to go into detail and one
construction so you understand what's
going on and then I'll go through these
details and i will not describe any
other results but you understand the
idea of how we did this or i can go on
and tell your statement of two other
result so any preference
I go to the details or should I go for
the other results okay so yes sure psv
as far as i remember you use an
idealistic condition constructor as
amended verify exactly right and it's
not amazing exactly this and executor
does not imply in trouble of ammunition
exactly so you cannot construct music
right and i can't either you see I'm not
playable and we can in war since the
desert oh the but it's not like the
designated verify none Interactive's
your knowledge that they use is none
black box it uses KU clever in
reductions they basically build
designated verifier none Interactive's
your knowledge for some NP language
using some reduction so it's not black
box in exactly the same way that this is
not black box yeah any other questions
yeah domain sure give them advice
efficiently strong man in the middle i
can never tell who I'm talking to
because i can always go to the man in
the middle who's talking to the other
side so there's got to be something in
the proof that doesn't cover this case
so I mean you cannot prevent a man in
the middle that jazz takes what let's
say unum in the middle if you take what
i sent you and you pass it on it's the
same as if I passed it but this this
protects me from if I send you something
that's protected from you changing into
anything else that dependent and passing
it on so I can prevent direct passing in
many cases you can say it's fine a few
men in the middle if you directly pass
and you don't change what I said and
this would prevent you from changing
what I said but yeah it's a question of
even you know all the digital goods it's
like you know how can you prevent even
if this is not really about what I'm
talking about here but in general even
the copyright protection I mean you can
always copy like it's just digital
stream how you know you can always copy
it what can you do so it so it's kind of
similar to that well they're right so
you need to assume something the answer
is so first of all it's a very good
question it's a big problem in crypto I
guess the simple answer is you know you
need to assume something like you assume
you have a public key infrastructure
sure and she believes the public key and
that's why public infrastructure is a
big deal and that's why it has to be
very public and very available and very
easy to verify their certification
authorities it's a big question in
crypto in general okay so so to
summarize this result we did achieved
non malleability mental abilities this
the level of security you need for
things like auctions where you want
independence okay next we want to ask
about chosen ciphertext attack can we
protect against chosen ciphertext attack
okay and i remind you that chosen
ciphertext attack is the attack where
the adversary gets temporary access to
the decryption oracle ok so can give
ciphertext and get decryptions obviously
if she can give in cipher text and get
the decryption she knows the decryption
because the decryption Oracle gave it to
her but what we want to prevent is we
want to prevent forgetting anything else
okay so from so if there is a specific
cipher text you want to decrypt we want
her to not be able to decrypt it even if
she can submit any other cipher text
that you want to the decryption Oracle
okay that's chosen ciphertext attack
it's a very important problem encrypted
it has many applications are where where
if you can break the chosen ciphertext
attacks security that your system would
not be good enough and the question is
can we construct it from semantically
secure public key encryption okay
without any extra assumptions in a black
box way or in a non black box way
whatever way and the answer is we don't
know that's the ultimate answer I don't
know it's a big problem big open problem
if anybody can solve it is very
interesting in crypto whether black box
or not black box if there's any way to
take semantically secure encryption and
build or show that it's hard to build
CCA secure encryption it will be very
interesting but I'll tell you what we do
have which are two partial answers so
one answer is everything I just said
that I didn't show you the details of
the same construction can in fact be
used pretty easily to achieve bounded
CCA security what is bounded CCA
security you remember that CCA security
chosen ciphertext attack securities when
Alice can access the
Oracle so if you knew in advance that
you can access the decryption Oracle no
more than this many times no more than n
times and you want to protect against
that if you knew that in advance then
you kill build an encryption scheme that
protects against up to n access to the
decryption Oracle okay so this is
bounded CCS if you know a priori what's
the maximum number of times you could
access it okay so if this is how you
define if you define bounded CCA then we
can in fact constructed from
semantically secure public key
encryption in an easy extension of the
result I mentioned before I just
mentioned of the nun malleability okay
that that's actually not hard to extend
a nun malleability reason to bounded CCA
yeah be practical in anyway so um let me
think about how to answer it so first of
all depends what the a priori bound is
one thing that's not practical tell you
why it is practical and why it's not
practical one thing that's not practical
is if you know the a priori bound the
sizes of your new public keys and the
sizes of your cipher text and everything
would depend on that a priori bound so
if you know that you will access it many
times in then you need like long public
keys in that sense it's not practical
it's there is a dependence and the
dependence is not great it is practical
in the sense that it's all linear the
number of times you call the underlying
scheme is linear so at least
theoretically it's practical it's more
practical than you know definitely way
way way more practical than ddn say okay
so it's the most practical one from the
general assumptions it's not as
practical as Kramer shoop okay okay good
so this is the yes answer now what about
general Sisi when people define CCA they
don't talk about bounded they talk about
you know you don't know how many times
you'll access it so for general CCA we
kind of have an answer of no okay what
does it mean kind of so this is another
paper we showed that we showed that in
fact when unbounded CCA
you cannot you cannot take semantically
secure encryption and build a CCA secure
encryption in a black box way ok so we
almost show that I'll give a caveat in a
second but we want to say that given a
given a semantically secure encryption
can you use it in a black box way to
build CCA ok and when you want to say
that the answer is no there's a whole
line of work separating cryptographic
primitives called black box separation
results where you show that you can't do
it in a black box way ok so we kind of
showed that you can do it in a black box
way why do I say kind of in fact we
didn't show it for any possible black
box construction we showed it for a
large class of black box construction
called shielding black box construction
what does it mean I'll tell you what it
means if the new remember you start from
GED that assumed to be semantically
secure and suppose that I could build a
new g prime e prime D prime that are CCA
either CCA one or CCA to it's all true
for both of them suppose from GED I
could build g prime e prime D prime so
I'm saying this is not possible if the
construction is black box and if my e
prime never calls d ok that's what
shielding means there's some technical
thing saying then create a new
encryption algorithm doesn't call the
old decryption algorithm ok um so as I
said the the real question of whether
you can do it is still open so what
about non shielding reductions I don't
know I used to have this conjecture that
you can't but I'm not going to stand
behind it like we really don't know and
it's an interesting problem ok um good
so you know what I won't go into any
details because then when I finish the
talk if there is time which there might
be then I can give details about your
favorite result and if there is no time
I won't ok it seems better to me ok so
this is the same with a picture we show
that there's no black box shielding
construction from cpa to CCA to in
particular it separates it shows that
CCA to is really stronger in some
inherent way than than malleable
encryption
good so I'm basically done with my first
two bullets but what all i did is
describe what the result it is and state
the result so if you have any questions
about these first two things feel free
let me just say in one sentence for non
malleability we said we can do it we can
achieve it it's a good construction it's
fairly practical and for CCA security we
can achieve limited and we have some
negative results for black box
constructions that are shielding ok the
next and last one I wanted to describe
to you is regarding adaptive security is
a little bit of a change of gears so
really this is a good time for questions
about the previous stuff ok so now I'm
going to talk about trapdoor simulate
about public key encryption for adaptive
security so why is this a change of
gears what's the change of gear so first
of all so far I talked specifically
about public key encryption ok and I
didn't really motivate why we need
public key encryption because I think
you all know that but what I'm going to
talk about next is not really public key
encryption I'll have public key
encryption as a tool but my ultimate
goal that I'm talking about now is
secure computation secure protocols
among multiple parties ok my concrete
result will be specifically about public
key encryption but only as it's used as
a tool within multi-party computation ok
so that's one change of gears and the
other change of gears will be that my
ultimate result will use some extra
assumptions not just semantic security
encryption ok so let me quickly talk
about secure computation so I'm talking
about secure protocols there's a bunch
of parties now it's not necessarily
encryption where I want to send a
message it's more there's a bunch of
parties they want to compute something
they want to compute it securely I won't
go into the definition of it because
I'll really only talk about the public
key encryption part but i'll talk about
the attack model so a non-adaptive or a
static attack model in a secure protocol
is where the adversary in advance let's
say you are all participating in a
secure protocol and I'm the adversary
and none of that fifth case is where I
will decide okay I'll break into
you and into you and into you and that's
what I'm going to do where's an adaptive
adversary is one where I will be like
okay I'm only breaking into you let's
see what's going on I'll see some
message of them based on a message at
other side okay now I want to break into
you okay so an adaptive adversaries
wondered as the protocol is ongoing in
the middle of the protocol may decide
who else to break into okay an adaptive
security is more difficult to achieve
then for static adversary in some
there's even some precise meaning to
this more difficult but I won't go into
it and it turns out that all previous
protocols that that achieve adaptive
security for arbitrary corruptions
arbitrary corruptions means if the
adversary may corrupt more than half of
the participants if the adversary make
up more than half of the participants
there was no known protocol that
achieved it in a black box way okay from
any underlying general primitive okay so
the only non protocols were non black
box and very inefficient for adaptive
security okay and moreover they all used
something called non committing
encryption which I won't define and it
doesn't matter what it is if you don't
know what it is they all use non
committing encryption but the only
assumptions concrete assumptions we knew
how to instantiate non commanding
encryption with was RSA and cdh
basically it's a computational
diffie-hellman basically the only
assumptions we knew how to instantiate
adaptive security from where either
factoring guerrilla like our essay or
diffie-hellman that's the script log
related yes are there any other line
probably schemes and accept are there
any yes so um first of all there is
elliptic curve stuff that's one line you
ask about what other types of
assumptions they are oh it might work
for a lipstick curves actually it's
weird they have it they have there's
another one with the DD h it might work
for elliptic curve um you're right and
other assumptions that that are kind of
starting to be popular today is lattice
based assumption and learning based
assumptions which are kind of related so
there's learning with error priority
would know as a random codes all these
things that I'm saying or kind of the
same there are different variations of
the same assumption
and all related to lattices and one good
thing about them is that at least for
now these new assumptions we don't know
how to break even with a quantum
computer these we know how to break in a
quantum computer that's one example and
in general just having more assumptions
it's good um yeah we can hear you there
are also mantovani completion or the
couch only use egg and cheese techniques
for y'all yeah they don't achieve
adaptive security they didn't achieve
adaptive there are protocols achieving
adaptive security is less than half of
the parties are corrupted or if mornin
has the parties are corrupted but they
were none black box at least this is
true for as of when we did our result
which is in fact actually very new it's
going to appear in asia this year
um okay I mean this kind of combines two
results but one of them appeared in TCC
last year and one of them will appear in
Asia crypt next year okay so here here
are results so first of all we define
something this I want to define for you
because I think it's a good primitive if
you ever design anything else that's
even unrelated to this it's a good
primitive to use I think something
called trapdoor simulator Val public key
encryption this is where the public key
encryption theme comes back in so we'll
define trouble simulator public key
encryption we will show it's basically
depends on previous work as well this is
not this just using previous work we
will show how they can be used in a
black box way to achieve adaptively
secure protocols for any functionality
and we will show how to construct this
trapdoor simulative a public key
encryption from lattice based assumption
than from factoring oh so so you asked
about RSA and cd8 it wasn't known for
example based on factoring our sayin
factoring is not the same right so now
we did it also based on factoring and
also based on either spaced assumptions
and in under things so what I want to do
is is define it just basically define
what travelers similar the Republic
encryption is because I think it's a
useful primitive to know we kind of
invented it but it's a variation of
something that was known before and I
think it's a useful one because
even you know trapdoor permutation it's
the most useful the most you know common
primitive that people use even that we
don't know how to do based on discrete
log based assumptions we don't know how
to do it based on learning so so this is
I think a new good general primitive to
use okay so i'll define traveler
simulator for public key encryption and
that's it then i'll just state the
results okay so here's the definition of
travelers emulator the public key
encryption if you didn't follow the last
part of the talk it doesn't matter
that's a new definition okay we will use
it for adaptive security of protocols
but okay so what is it is a regular
public key encryption semantically
secure public key encryption plus two
properties these two properties are very
worthy but are easy to explain and I'll
show an example it's easy to explain
them so the properties let me say the
first one the properties one property is
oblivious sampling what is oblivious
sampling so in a regular public key
encryption algorithm the key generation
algorithm generates a public key and a
secret key right so Bolivia's sampling
of the public key means there is a way
to generate a public key that's
distributed exactly the same without in
fact knowing what the secret key is okay
can you generate a public key where you
don't know the secret key okay this
needs to be defined exactly but this is
what it is that's oblivious generation
of the public key and also believe is
generation of a ciphertext what is the
easiest way to generate a ciphertext
that distributed correctly is okay take
a random message and encrypt it you get
a ciphertext okay oblivious generation
says can you generate a cipher text
without knowing what message it belongs
to okay that's why i believe is
something is this property is is easily
achieved for some protocols and is
already known protocols of public
encryption immediately an immediate
property that already exists and is hard
or we don't know how to do it for some
other public key encryption okay so
that's oblivious sampling and the second
property is trapdoor invertibility what
is trapdoor invertibility so let's say
you generated the public key correctly
with the key generation algorithm you
have a public key and a secret key can
you claim that you generated the public
key randomly without knowing the secret
key that's the invertibility if i
generated it correctly but then i want
to pretend like a generator that using
the
oblivious generation algorithm can I do
that ok so I think it's hard to
understand from this let me just give an
example it's much easier to see what an
example let's see the el-gamal example
so this is what i wrote before that's
the standard el-gamal encryption i'll
show you that it already has these
properties ok so recall an alga mal
encryption the key generation the key
the public key is PGH and the secret
keys x and p is a prime and GNH or
generators h is due to the X won't be ok
and encryption so let's do them key
generation first so an oblivious key
generation would be very simple you
would just choose PGH at random so P you
generate the prime choose a g8 random H
at random sure h is equal G to D X for
some X but you don't know what X is we
don't know how to do it so it's very
easy and this is distributed the same
because G&H you're basically random ok
so it's easy to see that it has this
oblivious key generation and also has
oblivious ciphertext generation because
the real encryption if you want to
encrypt a real message m you choose a
random are and you do G to D r and h to
the r times M right that's the real
encryption but if you wanted to generate
it obliviously you just choose random
elements in the in the group c1 and c2
ok because H to the r times M is random
so if you choose a random c1 to c2 this
is a valid encryption but you don't know
of what ok so al-jamal easily has it and
these are also invertible what does it
mean invertible let's say i generated
something correctly so i chose p and g
and h and i know the secret key I can
always lie and say oh I chose a chat
random I have no idea what the discrete
log is ok so el-gamal satisfies it i'm
giving you these examples i want to go
far with any technical details but i
just want you to explain what what this
assumption is simple travelers emulator
for public key encryption now for
factoring based public key encryption
it's not as easy so I wanted to give you
an example where it's not obvious how to
do it for El Gamal it's obvious you just
choose everything at random and it's the
right distribution so for example for
our essay or for Robin public key
encryption what is the public key you
choose n that's the product of two large
Prime's P and Q that seems hard at least
it's not obvious immediately how to
choose a number that equals the product
of two large primes without knowing what
the large primes are
okay it seems hard so this means that
the belief is key generation seems hard
to come by okay not clear how to sample
so this is what i believe is key
generation is we also want to talk about
oblivious ciphertext generation so for
example if the ciphertext in rabun
crypto system or in a decrypter system
the ciphertext often involves finding a
square for example mod n okay so how do
you find a random square more than or
sometimes it's part of a longer
ciphertext I'm kind of cheating because
rabun like M square more than is not
really an encryption scheme is more
trapdoor imitation but it doesn't really
matter even in the in the public key
encryption schemes based on it you
always have to choose a random square so
how do you choose a random square well
it's fairly easy right you choose a
number and you square it that's a random
square but then you know the square root
so how do you choose a random square
without knowing the square root it's not
obvious okay because we don't really
know how to have to test whether numbers
and let's consider it hard so this is
something that doesn't that doesn't have
of leave this key generation okay so
this is the definition of trapped
extremely durable public key encryption
is public key encryption that does have
those properties that you can generate
the public key obliviously and you can
generate the ciphertext obliviously okay
if you know what enhanced rhabdo
permutations are it's kind of very
similar to die so and this is the same
definition that was before so we didn't
invent this this was given by damn
garden Nielsen they defined simulate
about public key encryption and we
changed it a little bit but what did we
get from it here's a summary of how so I
told you that this has all kinds of
things I didn't define and I will not
define but I told you we start from
travelers ineligible public key
encryption and we get malicious
multi-party computation this is a
multi-step process the pink ones are our
results and the grey ones are none that
results and all of them rely on under
result but the bottom line is um so
after we defined traveller simulator of
a public key encryption on one hand we
showed how you can achieve them from all
assumptions but we know from factoring
learning with our that's lattice based
assumption DD HRSA we showed how to
construct them
and then using them we have a sequence
of results that lead you to malicious
multi-party computation for any all in a
black box that's a big deal that it's
all in a black box going through a non
committing encryption I didn't want to
define it because it's too many
definitions but if you care I think you
care about and I'm committing encryption
the so the first result just shows how
to get none committing encryption from
travelers relatable public key
encryption in two rounds okay optimal
round and once you get it we already
know how to get oblivious transfer film
it from previous work and then we showed
a compiler going from semi honest to
believe is transferred to malicious
oblivious transfer in a black box manner
yes with that one how can you have a
trap the trapdoor for the oh jen where
you generate something totally random
and yeah so the trapdoor invertibility
is this it's fun that you have trapdoor
bet trapper incredibility is this let's
say you generated it not at random not
oblivious we you generated with the key
generation algorithm with the secret key
can you lie and claim that you generated
in the oj okay so if you have the
trapdoor and readability means if you
have the trapdoor if you have the secret
key can you come up with randomness to
then lie and say here's the randomness
and used and here's how i got it so for
the example i gave well the mal it's
trivial yeah if you chose P&G and then
you chose X and you're the G to the X
equal h and then I come to you and say
how did you choose that you're like oh I
flipped random coins and I got G and I
flipped more random coin and I got H you
don't have to tell me you chose X and
the G to D X that's and that's
invertibility even without trapdoor
anybody could do that trapdoor and read
abilities if you hadn't is you know if
you have the secret key you can claim
that you generated it obliviously
because in all these algorithms it will
be used somehow there will be some
simulator that will choose it in this
way I will choose everything in the
correct way but will claim to have
chosen and to obliviously and willing to
explain it ok so um I won't go into
there's something about in the UC
setting or nothing to you see setting
ignore it let me just summarize all the
results it's exactly I'm exactly on time
so after the talk is over i can give you
details on whatever you want if anybody
wants to talk to me here's a summary i
talked about many things so
here's a summary of the results that I
showed so first of all we showed from
semantically secure public key
encryption without any further
assumption we can achieve man
malleability and bounded CCA and we
cannot achieve full CCA for shielding
black box constructions and we also
showed from semantically secure public
key encryption with this extra property
of oblivious generation travelers
immutability we can build nan committing
encryption and from it adaptively secure
protocols for any functionality against
an adversary didn't corrupt as many
parties as you want ok the results I
didn't mention I'm keep mentioning them
just in case you want to ask me
afterwards is we have both positive and
negative both possibility and
impossibility results for some physical
attacks lucky tampering or key leakage
ok and i think that's it ok any more
questions yeah so the definition of men
committing encryption is an encryption
where it's a regular encryption
semantically secure encryption with an
extra property that I seem it so you
know an encryption you have encryptions
of 0 and encryptions of one I might have
a slide on this let me see for one
second no it's not here oh well I'll
tell you the definition so it's a
regular encryption on a regular
encryption of encryptions of 0 and
encryptions of one and they're disjoint
right and everything is either
encryption of 0 encryption of 19
committing encryption is where
encryption of 0 and encryptions one and
not really disjoint there's some small
set of things that could be either
encryption of 0 or encryptions of one
and where if you encrypt correctly you
want to encrypt a zero you encrypt a
zero you want to encrypt the one you
encrypt the one you're extremely
unlikely almost for sure you'll never
hit something in the intersection but if
you're a simulator or if you some
special party you could generate them
from the intersection so basically an
implementing encryption is when if I'm
not the right party I'm just cheating I
can generate something that's an
encryption that later I can prove that
it was an encryption of zero or prove
that was an encryption of one
and this is used as a tool for all
existing result that achieve adaptive
secure encryption yeah yeah yeah how do
i define a bleep is sampling um yeah um
did i do not define it so oblivious
sampling oh how do you define the this I
don't know the secret key what does it
mean that I don't know the secret key
that's a good question yeah because I
can always say Oh choose secret key
public key and then forget the secret
key and that will not be good enough so
the way I define it is i define that the
scheme is still semantically secure even
if i chose the public key so let's say I
chose the public key with this oblivious
way I want that if I have all the random
coins that were used to choose it so I
have an algorithm Oh Jen get some random
corn and generates a public key I
wondered even if i have the random coins
that told me how i generated this public
key the scheme is still semantically
secure forget an encryption I have no
idea how to break it whereas if you
generated it in the naive way of
generating a secret key in a public key
it's not secure right obviously you can
decrypt anything an external party or
you can think of it as an internal party
that generated it using the oblivious
generation algorithm so if you're
generally I'm just answering you about
the key but it would be the same thing
for the ciphertext so you want both of
them for the key you want to say that if
I generated the key using Oh Jen that
means I got a key like for example for
elder male generated p g and h and I
really that's how I generated them I
chose a P correctly and then I chose a
random G and a random h ok then now if
you give me some el de mal encryption I
it's semantically secure I will have no
idea what you encrypted ok even though I
know exactly how I generated them with
Oh Jen and the same for four so that's
for the key and the same for the
ciphertext generation so you know for
example if I chose a message and square
it and got in got an M squared and I
know then it's not semantically secure I
know what the square root is so you
wanted to remain semantically secure
even if you chose it like this ok we
have a definition and damn gar Nielsen
had a definition I can show you I
probably
have it I can find it in a slight I'll
show you after the talk somebody else
had a question I remember you yes public
in nature is that chosen plaintext is a
passive attack run as an active attack
yes and now that it's gotta be critical
because if you use a one-time pad it's
totally semantic security is totally
malleable so yes where does this Howard
this proof break when you use it when
you apply them to the tools at one time
that um yeah I see a question that's a
good question um let me see hold on a
second wait let me find um I kind of
wanted to show this this is our
construction and you can ignore all the
details but the way so this PK you have
some encryption scheme that semantically
secure and you want to build none mal
evil scheme out of it so the way you do
it in some way of choosing many many
pairs of keys okay in some way it
doesn't matter I'm just showing you two
I'm trying to think how to so you
generate me so the way you do it is by
repetition basically the way you do it
is you generate many public use of the
underlying skin and you encrypt the same
thing many times using these public keys
with one-time pad this construction
won't work because so it's not that the
security won't work you you can't even
encrypt let me think how to say so so
it's not no its private key encryption
and it is very malleable you asking why
if I applied this in whatever
construction we have if i apply to a
secret key encryption were like will I
get yeah um you know we might you've
seen what we actually might get none
malleability when we apply because when
we apply our construction it will no
longer be one time dad it will be one
time pad repeated many times with some
extra proof of something with some extra
cut and choose because we don't use the
same scheme we change it so in fact our
construction will work also for secret
key encryption yeah yes so the truth is
we don't use it directly there are two
stages there so there are two different
stages tell me which one you want me to
elaborate on or both first we use travel
amount of a public key encryption for
non committing encryption okay that's
when construction and I can show you how
to do it and that's not really related
to adaptive security so it's just non
committing encryption is what I was
entering before nine committing
encryption is that you can and you have
some special way to generate ciphertext
that can be opened both ways okay and I
can tell you how just intuition how to
use travelers relatable public key
encryption to generate non committing
encryption okay that's one aspect and
another aspect is how to use non
committing encryption for adaptively
secure computation and that's another
aspect so um I think you're asking more
to set the second one okay how to use
non committing encryption for so okay so
the way you do so let's assume you have
non committing encryption I'm committing
encryption is something where you can
generate sephadex that you can open
either way so the way to do it is the
following so for so let's say we have a
secure computation protocol okay then we
know is secure for non-adaptive
adversaries okay so we all run the
protocol and we know if the adversary
knew in advance we broke into it was
secure how do we get adaptive security
so what is the problem with adaptive
security the problem with adaptive
security is the adversary is here and he
sees what's going on and he saw the
message you sent him and based on that
message he decided to break into you he
saw that messaging is like I had this is
your message I want to break into you
okay once he breaks into you you have to
show him out i forgot to say we assume
no erasers these achieving adaptive
security is easier if you assume that
you can safely erase everything we do we
assume you don't erase anything so let's
say I'm the adversary I saw you sent I
didn't break into anybody yet I saw you
send some message to him it's encrypted
I can't read it but based on the message
i decided to break into you once I break
into you now your corrupted I tell you
show me what message did you
and when randomness did you use how did
you generate that cipher text from your
message ok the problem is when we want
to achieve security we have a simulator
we want to you know to show security we
want to show that in the ideal ward a
simulator can simulate everything so
before I broke into you the simulator
just generated something that's easy
just generate an encryption of anything
all the encryptions look at the same so
it's no problem so the simulator could
generate an encryption of zero it looks
the same as the encryption of whatever
it is you really send to him but the
problem is once I broke into you I see
your input and I have to explain what
you send him with what you really have
and this is where the non committing
encryption will come in is the simulator
will send something that could be open
both ways and then if I break to you if
I break into you I can see what you
committed to the way I described it now
is kind of a little cheating what I
described now is exactly how it was
defined non committing encryption by CF
GN canary Fagin or in gold rush ok they
define and committing encryption exactly
in the way I described it to you they
used it in exactly this way to simulate
secure channels you know how if you
forget about adaptivity we can assume we
have secure channels and then in reality
we don't have secure channel so we'll
use public key encryption instead so to
adapt if they use non committing
encryption instead of secure channels
and this is exactly how it work it turns
out for this setting the standalone
setting in fact at the end there's newer
results that don't even need any non
commanding encryption if they used it
for for you know if the adversary only
breaks into few people anyway the way I
describe it to you now is it's used
mountain for the UC selling for example
it's used in somewhat more sophisticated
ways but the intuition is the same it's
supposed to simulate a secure channel
where I first saw what was going on and
then I broke into you and now I need to
explain and I can't change my mind
anymore like this is the message it was
sent now I have to explain this message
as an encryption of what your real
inputs are so that's how non-competing
encryption is use their yeah
stand-alone only function yes I can um
okay these are our results so um we
built from semi honest oblivious so we
built non-committee encryption and it's
already known by buy clothes it's a
kinetic lindell Ostrovsky and say hi
showed how to use non-committee
encryption for semi honest OT ok and
then for semi honest we show the
compiler that goes from semi honest
oblivious transfer to malicious
oblivious transfer but I've compiler
doesn't really not use anything else it
uses some commitment ideal commitment
functionality ok so you would ask you
were cheating all along you were saying
you don't want any extra assumption what
is this extra assumption that you're
adding here commitment so this extra
assumption can be achieved in the UC
setting with some common random string
or some other setup but what I wrote
before is in the standalone model it's
not really an extra assumption because
commitment comes from one-way function
so we can remove it completely because
even if you had just public key
encryption that already implies one with
action already implies commitments or in
fact it does not require any extra
assumption yeah games for me RSA what it
looks like or you go yeah um yeah let me
think yeah um let me see
um
for a minute is this the right thing how
to construct a bruisin learn about
mccain christian based on harness or
factoring that's that's kind of what you
are asking right um I specifically said
that it's hard to construct this
oblivious sampling for factoring based
stuff right so what are we going to do
so let me think about what the most
important parts are so there's the
generation of the public key and there's
the ciphertext the ciphertext let's say
is X square and the public is N equals P
times Q okay for and we want to generate
them both so how do we do it it doesn't
have anything so first of all so it will
change the scheme so first of all we'll
say we want to allow any integer and it
doesn't have to be the product of two
primes okay once you say that we know
how to it's not easy but we know it's
not trivial but it's a known result of
how to sample random integers with their
factoring with your factoring okay so so
now I'm changing it so that any n is
fine even if it's not P times Q okay so
that's easy I mean we'll still need to
show that some security homes and that
something happens ok now another problem
is it was important that squaring was a
permutation if you know Arabian Raven
works and quadratic residues now once i
changed the end to be not necessarily p
times q it's no longer a permutation so
we change the domain instead of
quadratic residues the domain is all the
nut quadratic but a to the two to the K
okay we somehow change the domain all
these are like number theoretic theorems
but they're easy to prove the hard thing
is towards to notice how to do it and to
decide to do it and to figure it out so
you can show that squaring is a
permutation over this domain okk
specifically the length of n okay so you
can show it's a permutation good and
it's hard to invert the same way that a
rabun is hard to invert for N equals P
times Q so I mean not this this is Robin
says that if N equals P times Q it's
hard to invert so now I define the
scheme for any end but the hardness to
red is only on N equals P times Q that's
fine because that's a sizable fraction
of ends okay I'll manage to use it okay
so this shows you that squaring is now I
got a weak trapdoor permutation okay
week in the sense that it might be easy
to invert if n doesn't happen to be
equal to P times Q but if it does then
it's hard okay so that's one change with
it um okay I mean if there's many
details let me think okay so at the end
of the day what I'll do is I'll choose
many ends and it now i'll choose enough
ends so that i know that it's very
likely that at least one of them happens
to be a blom integer so we don't know
how to generate blam integers n equals p
times q 4p equals three month for and Q
equals three month for so we don't know
how to generate a blam integer without
knowing the factorization but we can
generate just a bunch of random numbers
enough of them such that they're dense
enough such that one of them is likely
to be a blam integer yes billion little
beads right there hun 16-bit number of
you Harbor million thousand bit numbers
are better video you're just doing k to
the turn yeah yeah yeah um it's true
yeah um I guess wait no no it's more
than hell so anyway um this is the
oblivious generation I feel like this
doesn't answer your question right yeah
so I wanted to understand if the
construction that you have fracturing or
are saying in particular took into
account or could take into account the
fact long ten people use RSA these days
there's formatting inside of the wit
message gets converted right we don't
yarn when you think about it right over
here at the perspective week about
taking em and we exponentiate around
about the format of that but when we use
it in practice there's all of this
padding of randomization happens which
it seemed would interfere with your
ability to generate the appropriate
oblivious sampling right because as you
have to be a little blood sample
something that's a ciphertext right
right I see what you're saying yeah
that's kind of where I was I was going
in I understand either yes the stroke it
won't interfere and I understand your
question at one interfere because we
also don't in the wii theoreticians also
don't use our essay as it is because
that's not semantically secure even so
in practice the way it's used is some
paddings of specific format whereas in
theory the way it's used is this using a
hardcore bit so okay so so so it doesn't
matter as long as if you assume that
whatever way you use is semantically
secure then it will work okay so it
doesn't assume that it doesn't the way
the protocol voice is like it generates
a bunch of I don't know into the fourth
or some number of ciphertext we're not
into the fourth sorry and some linear
number of ciphertext where a quarter of
them were chosen obliviously and three
quarter of them were chosen correctly
you encrypted em and three-quarters of
them were chosen obliviously you you
wanted the distribution of the oblivious
to be the same as the distribution of
the correct one so this will be
guaranteed if I don't know if it's
guaranteed for like ad hoc ways to
construct RSA encryption but it is
guaranteed if it's if you guarantee your
thing is semantically secure than I
guarantee it'll work